Hi, welcome back. In this session, I
want to continue our discussion of
trading on information by focusing on
insiders and companies. The conventional
complaint you get from investors often
is we're on the outside looking in, but
there are people inside the firm, close
to the firm, have access to information
than you and I don't. Now, that's true,
right? And in this session, I'd like to
focus on is information on what those
people are doing useful to you as an
outside investor. I'm going to start
with insiders as defined by the law.
Those include managers, directors, major
stockholders, people own more than 5% of
shares of a company. Legally, these
people are constrained from trading
ahead of information, right? Ahead of
earnings reports, ahead of acquisition
announcements, but they're still allowed
to buy and sell shares. And to the
extent that we can observe what when
they're buying and when they're selling,
is that information that's useful to us
as outsiders.
I would also argue that there are equity
research analysts tracking the company
and while they legally might not be able
to access public information, they might
have access to information about a
company that you and I don't. And by
observing what those analysts are doing
in terms of revising earnings or putting
out buy and sell recommendations,
can we trade on that to make money? So,
we're going to start by looking at both
session at least by focusing on whether
insiders themselves make money. And if
the answer is yes, then ask a follow-up
question. Can tracking what insiders do
make the rest of us money? So, let's
start with a study that goes back a long
time. In this study, the the researchers
looked at companies where insiders were
buying net buys and companies where
insiders were selling. Remember,
insiders buy and sell stock. You look at
the net amount. So, the red line
captures companies where insiders were
buying. The green line captures what
insiders were selling in the months
after the insider trade. Seems like a
no-brainer, right? in stocks where
there's a lot of insider buying do much
better than stocks with a lot of insider
selling. When this study came out,
people said this is great. We can now
make money on this. We'll come back and
examine whether that's true. But at
least in the aggregate, there seems to
be some information here. And companies
were insiders are more buyers than
sellers. That's good news. Stock prices
tend to go up and companies where more
insiders are more sellers than buyers.
Stock prices tend to either flatten out
or go down. Now, in the years since this
study, there's been a deeper look at
insider trading. And here's what people
have found. The first is that insider
buying and selling is a noisy signal.
What does that mean? In about four of 10
stocks where insiders are buying, the
stock price actually goes down. It
doesn't go up. The same is true for
insider selling. And it turns out that
if it's a signal, it's a noisy signal.
So, if you're buying because insiders
are big, be cautious. About four times
in 10, you're going to be wrong. It
turns out also if you focus on insider
buying versus insider selling
stronger signal than buying. When
insiders are selling, you're far more
likely to see stock prices go down than
when insiders are buying, stock prices
going up. For whatever reason, selling
has a much bigger signaling effect. In
fact, one study found that insiders
selling now had companies where there
was a lot of insider selling had stock
returns of 14.4%.
significantly lower than the 20 22% you
had in firms with insider buying and the
insider trading effect is much greater
at small firms. We'll talk we'll come
back and talk about why that might be.
But if you see insider buying at a small
firm, it's much more likely to be
followed by a stock price rise than if
it's at a large firm. Noisy signals
selling is a stronger signal than buying
in at least on the part of insiders and
much stronger at smaller firms. So,
let's update many of these studies
because insider laws have shifted and
and tightened over time. The SEC has
become much more expansive in its
definition of what comprises insider
information and more aggressive in its
enforcement of those laws. So, it's
selective. Companies are also much more
restricted in what they can share with
investors. There was a time where
companies could call in 20 equity
research analysts that tracked them,
gave them information that the rest of
the market did not get. That's no longer
possible. In fact, regulation FD, which
was passed in 2002, effectively made it
much more difficult for companies to
share information with some investors
and not with others. One of the things
we've discovered in in the studies is
the effect of insider trading seems to
have become much smaller since now
remember all these studies of insider
trading focus on legal insider trading.
And by making it more difficult for
insiders to trade by by defining insider
information more stringently might have
taken away the profitability of insider
trading.
Now, of course, as outsiders, you're not
a director, you're not a manager, you're
not a person who owns 5% of the shares
in a company. You're not an equity
research analyst. We'll talk about
analysts later in the next session. So,
can I make money by looking at what
insiders are doing at first gra at when
you take your first look at the insider
studies, it looks like you do. In fact,
the early studies looked at the returns
following when the insider reporting
date was because insiders have to file
by a particular date. It took that date
and said, you know, what would stock
prices do? And you can see if you bought
stocks after insider buying reporting
dates, stock prices continue to go up.
But then researchers realized that that
the insiders report to the SEC, it's not
the date where the that information
becomes publicly disclosed. If you take
the actual public disclosure date,
that's your official summary date, and
you look at the returns thereafter, it's
almost nothing. So the bottom line is
knowing what insiders are doing is more
valuable if you knew it in time. If you
knew it when they filed, but since you
don't know it till 3, four, five weeks
later, it turns out that you can't make
much money on it. So should you look at
what insiders are doing? Absolutely. Can
you make money on it? I'm not so sure.
In fact, as you go to online
disclosures, that period between the
reporting date and summary date is
compressing, but the consequences are
not changing. After it becomes official,
it becomes much more difficult to make
money on insider information.
Now, digging deeper into that insider
trading research, it turns out that not
not all insiders are equal because you
can have a small manager who buys a 100
shares and you can have a CEO who buys a
million shares. And this shouldn't come
as a surprise. Large trade made by top
executives have a much bigger pricing
impact and create excess returns than
small trades by by lower level
executives. And as investment
alternatives to shares become more
available, options and perhaps you know
volat
futures on stock. It turns out that
insiders might do their trading there
rather than in the market. So you might
want as an outside investor, you might
want to track jump trading in that
market. And one way you can track it is
by looking at trading volume. If trading
volume on call options on a stock jumps,
especially if it's a lightly traded
stock, it might be because insiders are
trading on those call options. So it is
clear that insider trading has an
effect, but whether you can trade on
that effect is much more diffuse.
Finally, insider trading information is
more useful in some companies than
others. And we talked about small
companies versus large companies. Let me
generalize. In companies where
information is plentiful, there are 50
analysts tracking this stock, hundreds
of news stories, knowing what insiders
are doing is much less useful than in
small companies where there's far less
information, far fewer analysts
following it, know far fewer news
stories. So if you're going to track
insidered trading, the payoff might be
great if you track insidered trading in
small and below the radar companies and
in the large cap companies.
One of the questions we haven't examined
in this session and perhaps for a reason
is almost all of the research on insider
trading is on insiders who report
the insiders who report to the SEC are
the insiders who follow the law. don't
trade ahead of information.
But inside of trading which is illegal
is not going to get reported to the SEC
and we know conclusively that that kind
of trading
you know that your company's going to be
targeting an acquisition in a couple of
weeks and you find a way to trade a
ahead as the investor in that target
company in the two weeks before you're
going to make a ton of money. It is
pervasive. [clears throat] And the
reason we know it's pervasive is because
before big announcements, and we'll come
back and talk about in the context of
acquisition, there's a drift in the
price. So if it's a good news
announcement, the price starts to drift
up before the actual public
announcement. I'm cynical. That tells me
that there are people trading out there.
So illegal insider trading clearly makes
money. But perhaps the risk you got to
factor in there is you could get caught.
And if you're trading on an illegal
insider information, timing is key,
right? You got to get in at the right
time, get out at the right time. So
essentially with insider trading, as
with every other information aspect of
information trading, that aspect of when
you get in and when you get out might
determine whether you can make money on
the trading. So let's summarize what we
know about insiders. In the US for
decades now insider trading if you trade
ahead of information is illegal but if
you trade just based on general views on
a company you can buy and sell companies
and you got to file that you've done
that with the SEC the SEC makes it
public the research is mixed if you look
at the you know whether there's a drift
in the price at least in the across in
the cross-section it looks like insider
buying is you know followed by company
stock prices going up and insiders
selling by company stock prices going
down but as outsiders you might not be
able to make money on it because by the
time that information becomes public
almost all of the effect is incorporated
in the price as for illegal insider
trading all bets are off those guys make
money but since it's illegal there is
going to be no SEC filing and it's going
to be difficult for outsiders to track
that it's happening with a caveat which
is you might be able to guess there's
outsider there's illegal trading going
on by looking at trading volume or
looking at action in the options markets
because that's where illegal insiders
will go to trade. One final point, there
are markets out there now the
geographies are the countries where
managers and insiders are allowed to not
just trade but to provide information to
a subset of outside investors, analysts,
institutions in those in those markets
those investors have an advantage over
the rest of us. The downside is though
by giving that advantage and excess
return you create the perception and the
perception is based on a reality that
markets are not fair. What that
effectively does does is it means
outside investors are less willing to
partake in those markets. So many of
those markets there's a lack of
liquidity and people compl complain
about the lack of liquidity and people
not wanting to participate. But who can
blame them? If you've created a game
where you've tilted the game in favor of
insiders and people who are close to
insiders, of course outsiders will not
participate. So as you look across
markets, there might be markets where
inside information is legal for you to
trade on. And if you can become one of
those insiders who can take advantage,
all the more power to you. But those are
also going to be markets where your
transactions costs are higher. The price
impact is going to be much larger. I
hope you found the session useful and I
thank you very much for listening.